During lecture this week, we learned about context-free grammars and languages
and about parsing them. But is there anything beyond that?
Is there anything other than the context-free grammars
and the regular languages that we've learned so far?
Is there anything more powerful?
That's an excellent question.
It turns out that context-free grammars are not the end-all and be-all
of interpreting languages like JavaScript or HTML.
In fact, just as we saw that regular languages and regular expressions
weren't powerful enough to do everything we needed--
they couldn't handle balanced parentheses, so we couldn't use them for parsing--
it's going to turn out that context-free languages and context-free grammars
will only take us so far,
and we're going to use additional techniques like interpretation
or keeping track of local variables in order to find other things out.
Here's a great example of what the "free" in context-free actually means.
You might think, "Boy, is there a context-expensive grammar out there?"
"What's the opposite of free?"
It turns out in this domain the opposite of free is context-sensitive,
and it's going to turn out that the meaning of a program depends on its context.
For example, suppose I ask you what's X + 2?
The meaning of that program depends a lot on the local value of X.
So we're going to need something more than just parsing,
more than context-free grammars, to reason about programs
that include substrings like X + 2.
If right above it I've written X = 4, then X = 4, X + 2 yields 6.
But if right above it I've written X = 0, then we'd get a different answer.
That line above it is the context.
Our context-free grammar doesn't care about the line above it.
You can write down X + 2 even if you've never assigned to X before.
When we go to write our interpreter for JavaScript
and our ability to render web pages by interpreting HTML,
we're going to need to keep track of the context, the values, the variables,
what has gone before, our history.
All of that is going to matter for figuring out the true interpretations of programs.
So again, just as regular expressions weren't powerful enough
and we needed context-free grammars for parsing,
we're going to need something else, context sensitivity, to make our final web server.
And we're going to get to that in around Unit 5 in this class, so stay tuned.